le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a réagi à ces accusations de
la bulgarie à l'occasion d'une
conférence de presse avec son homologue
mexicain il a fait savoir avec son
ironie coutumière qu'à ce rythme on
accuserait bientôt la russie de tout et
n'importe quoi
cetto bon c'est encore heureux qu'on ne
nous accuse pas du meurtre de l'archiduc
ferdinand apparemment ça va venir
ce cadre chronologique lui-même qui
comprend ces dix dernières années
signifie que soit la bulgarie n'étaient
au courant de rien et c'est seulement
maintenant
après que la tchéquie s'est souvenu des
événements de l'année 2014 qu'elle a
décidé du surpasser même les tchèques et
d'aller encore plus loin dans le cadre
de cette rétrospective historique soit
pendant tout ce temps il était au
courant de ce qui se passait mais pour
certaines raisons ne le rendait pas
publique
je te reçois dire n'importe qui peut
nier la bulgarie suspecte donc à son
tour la russie d'être à l'origine de
l'explosion de plusieurs hangars
abritant des armes et munitions entre
2011 et 2020 pour des accusations
similaires prague a décidé il y a une
dizaine de jours d'expulser 18 diplomate
russe
suite à quoi moscou avait à son tour
envoyé 20 diplomate tchèque
mais voilà prague a été entre-temps
imité par les pays baltes et la
slovaquie qui se sont mis à expulser
aussi des fonctionnaires russes en signe
de solidarité
en réponse comme il est d usage dans ces
cas là la diplomatie russe a donc
convoqué aujourd'hui les ambassadeurs de
ces pays il aurait été signifiée le
renvoie à leur tour de cette diplomate 3
slovaques 2 lituanien un estonien et un
letton le ministère des affaires
étrangères russe déplore cette pseudo
solidarité des pays en question estime
qu'il poursuive en réalité une ligne
ouvertement hostile envers la russie